get reaction from retired arizona
national guard general
michael mcguire general good morning to
you
good morning steve thanks for having me
you bet so what do you make
of this particular thing the attorney
general in arizona sent a letter to dhs
expressing grave concerns opening this
hotel
into a migrant facility is that a good
idea
no you know and you mentioned vice
president harris not visiting uh the
biden administration has been derelict
in their duty
uh sending people here to the border to
see the impact on our communities
these conversions of hotels and leases
in the local area
are places where we are simply moving
families
that are overwhelming our communities
this crisis is growing
and they're being released after 48 to
72 hours
and they're putting huge pressures on
our uh local communities
and they're affecting our security
border security is a human security
issue
you're right and the problem is uh the
folks there in arizona feel that the
problem is
this migrant hotel facility
is in a residential neighborhood near a
school and that's why a lot of people
have a problem
listen at midnight word went out you
made a big announcement
you want to be the next senator from
arizona right
that's right uh steve i announced last
night officially that i'm running for
u.s senate in the great state of arizona
i served for nearly 34 years as a
commissioned officer and i believe that
the country
is in need of principled moral and
ethical leadership
and i'm looking to bring that as a
conservative
constitutionalist and i say the road to
51 leads through arizona the road to 51
leads to arizona
well the problem right now is uh we have
seen such a sea
change general in the migration and
immigration policies of this
administration you
say that the number one thing if you
were elected u.s senator
that you would uh really come down on
and focus on
would be border security and you're a
border state obviously this is something
you know
a lot about that's right uh i have uh
been in command for uh eight years as
the commander and
nearly 15 years in command total uh this
is the first administration that hasn't
committed to doing the things they need
to do
one is uh build a wall secure the border
physically
two provide the resources to the agents
that need to enforce that
right and then three make sure that we
look at
laws subsequent to those changes that
make us
all safer in our communities and if you
all believe that go to elect mick
elect mick dot com this is going to take
a
whole of nation effort to get some
balance back in the u.s senate
okay well i know that you will now have
announced you're running in the
republican primary you'd like to square
off against senator
mark kelly let's see how that all works
out uh general thank you very much for
joining us live
you bet thanks for having me steve